we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting question that came in about
maybe an unintended consequence of the
trump russia investigation let's take a
listen to it
Talia's father David just calling in
regards to the coverage that's been
going on a lot in the last six twenty
sixteen basically with the you know the
2016 election the hacking the you know
basically the Russia Gates story ask you
a question about that
in regards to that story throughout you
know the time since 2016 and the covers
and you know the left-wing right-wing
particularly on the left-wing wondering
if this coverage has inadvertently made
Trump somewhat of a sympathetic figure
you know there's some some media outlets
that constantly - Trump some without any
evidence you know there's there's it's
just so clear so the question is abrupt
ending the question is does the Trump
Russia investigation inadvertently make
Trump a more sympathetic character the
answer is yes but only to people who
already sympathize with them in other
words it or believe that the Trump
Russia investigation is bogus how anyone
can still argue that given the number of
years in prison cumulatively that have
been doled out as a result I don't know
how someone can still say that so yeah
if you believe that the Trump Russia
investigation is bogus and you are a
trumpet
you probably do feel bad that they're
going after Trump in this way but most
people are not in that boat and the
people who are either way our defenders
of Trump so I don't I understand what
the caller is saying Pat but I don't
think that the Trump Russia
investigation makes Trump a sympathetic
character in a way that materially
changes the balance of how people pursue
him right perceive him rather for me as
an entre to go around and I'm not gonna
waste it on some billionaire leader of
the free world who is committing crimes
and trying to get away with them like I
have higher priorities yeah
I completely agree with you and I think
that's a very good point on today's
bonus show I am going to talk to you
about what is taking place next week
with my jury duty I think people will
find this interesting also on the bonus
show Theresa may British Prime Minister
survives a no-confidence vote we will
talk about that we will talk about later
start times working well for teenagers
in Seattle I've been advocating for that
since I had to start high school at 7:25
in the morning and much more on today's
bonus show I would love to see you or
talk to you on the bonus show get access
by becoming a member at WWE and
pakman.com by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
soon by becoming a Youtube subscriber
member I guess it's called at
youtube.com slash the david pakman show
speak to you that